and we
are
live
let's do it
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen
welcome back
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome back to roofing
with griffin
big episode today
the new house of dragons
game of thrones prequel
i'm all in can't wait to start talking
about that
weekly
uh let's see what else is going on i saw
she-hulk
so then we gonna have a little review of
she-hulk
orcas apparently
do fads
so that's weird
and
you know a couple other things but we
out here
[Music]
is
[Music]
what's up y'all welcome to
riffin with griffin starring eric
griffin that's me welcome back to the
podcast please subscribe
um
what do you call a share
hit the notifications become a youtube
member if you want to help support the
show in many different ways you can
follow me on twitch
i do twitch
i'm also on twitch
and i'm also on uh patreon so you know
i'm not i'm trying to do a bunch of
content but it is what it is i'm a
one-man show but it's a way to support
me if you want to be like hey i like
what you do and here's this you can do
it in any bunch of those kind of ways
man you could be a youtube member a
patreon member you can go subscribe to
me on twitch that's another way that
helps out trust me it really does help
um
excuse me today's now a word from our
sponsor
all right now a word from our sponsor
better help
better help
easy and affordable online therapy get
10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
griffin that's better h-e-l-p-com
griffin for 10 percent off
all right y'all thanks for being here uh
i see the chat live want to give a shout
out to the chat thanks you guys for
being here always appreciate the super
chats i appreciate the interaction
um just appreciate you guys for being
here weekly and then listening
throughout the week for the people that
do that so that's pretty cool thank you
for doing that uh
what's going on uh this week oh man oh i
wish i would have put this picture
um
something weird that's like going on
man i should really i don't even know
how to do that but my buddy i'll just
show it on the on on the camera but a
buddy of mine my buddy cody shout out to
him he
like this is a cautionary tale for
everyone so he was sleeping and he put
his headphones he had his little earbuds
in you know for his headphones you know
and
he told me he woke up and he had a dream
that he was choking
and when he woke up he realized he had
swallowed
his earbuds
wow right and so they he's having a
procedure right now to get it removed
because and i have the he showed me the
x-ray and they showed him where it was
so oh i don't know if you could see that
um there it is right there okay i'm i'm
holding my phone up if you could see it
like right
there you can't really see it that well
but anyways it's the oh man
this is just me not being prepared but
it looks crazy
[Laughter]
you know what i mean like just like this
legit looks
this legit looks
crazy man you know
so
i don't know maybe you know what i could
probably you know you know what let me
let me let me put it up i'm still gonna
put it up because this thing is just
like
i don't even get this man you know you
go browse media
uh let's go to the desktop no no we go
to downloads uh
is that the picture i don't even know
wait can you see oh how does this work
yeah you know when you do stuff live
this is what happens y'all
how come you can't well that's crazy
that's crazy that you can't
see that picture i don't know what this
the new format of
i don't know what the new form what what
is h h-e-i-c
format that doesn't even make any sense
to me whatever this new format is i mean
they got
stu technology is moving so fast that
you don't even know
what stuff is anymore
right i mean does that does anybody even
know what that is that this new format i
mean i thought it was just like
jpegs and that kind of stuff so now it's
like you can't even you can't even keep
up with whatever it is that they're
coming out with they think they're you
know it's like they think they're
helping you you know what i mean they're
like oh we're gonna help you
by uh coming out with a new thing it's
like when apple comes out with a new
um
you know plug for their phone
and then you're just kind of like well
what do i do with these 85 other plugs
that i already have for this you know so
that's the crazy part but let me see i'm
gonna i think i think i could do this on
the fly as i'm talking about it i'm
trying to do it for y'all here we go
boom yeah i was able to do it
oh and there it is oh look at that right
isn't that crazy y'all isn't that crazy
you could you could uh you could see the
um
you could see the thing right there with
the people that are watching live and
thank you also for uh uh
you know all the youtube members and all
that kind of i mean all the people that
listen on spotify and apple podcasts and
all those places thanks for that but
look you can you guys see it right there
i mean isn't that bananas
like that's like oh my god like wow
see it right there oh man so anyways
that's pretty crazy that uh you that he
swallowed that so be careful with that
man
i don't have a tech guy but i should i'm
doing this by myself you know i got i
got to get wiggy to come back but you
know just he's busy we're both busy
both lazy too that's the problem um
somebody said looks like he shoved it up
his ass
well that's the like his spinal cord
guys this is from the back you know what
i mean
[Laughter]
you know so this is like it's like a
crazy you know they did an x-ray so i
don't know whatever um
so
that's that happened i just wanted to i
told him i said i'm talking about this
in my podcast it looks so weird so that
be careful man like i like to use
over-the-ear headphones i don't like
headphones
that are
you know and i don't like stuff in my
ear i just don't like that some people i
don't know what you guys think about
that but i like over-the-ear headphones
you know
more than i like um
more than i like the ones that are in my
ear it just feels weird you know i'll
put a pole up headphones
in the ear
over the ear okay which one you guys
like
so
there was that
um what else is going on i don't know i
feel scatterbrained you know what it is
today was about a really busy day like
you're going to see this same shirt in
three different podcasts i had to go do
king and a sting and then i had to go do
gender gen because we had this like life
coach guest on so make sure you check
out gender gen because actually very
fascinating the things he was talking
about one of the things i took from it
about this life coach that i thought was
like really mind-blowing for me
it's like when you have a thought
process and then somebody tells you a
different way so like he was talking
about trust and like when you talk to
someone and you go
you have to earn the trust
and the semantics of saying earn versus
build
and i was thinking about that and it was
like when you say someone has to earn
trust it means like it puts a power
dynamic where that person is like above
you and you're earning it and you have
to do certain things to earn as opposed
to
it being empowered by let's build trust
it's just a small change but it's like
it's so important that's so powerful to
think about the difference between those
two
and you know it's like what it means to
you know build trust with someone or
build trust in a situation as opposed to
like say i'm trying to earn it from you
and you build this weird power dynamic
it makes you feel bad it's so subtle but
i really enjoyed that
um
here's some here here's something like
sometimes you gotta sometimes you like
speaking of having a different
perspective on something
i come down to the living room and this
is where we're gonna we're gonna count
this one in some
rachel
updates
my beautiful wife rachel shout out to
her i come down into the living room
yesterday and she's watching wonder
woman on tnt uh the first one it's just
on you know and i just go i sit down and
i go oh i love this movie i i enjoyed
wonder woman i thought it was uh uh you
know enjoyable movie and then she's like
she has a different opinion on it she's
like i don't like this she's like how
come she doesn't have any lines
all she does is just say one thing and
all these men are talking through the
whole time and at first i was kind of
like okay here we go with that nonsense
right and i just was like all right
rachel relax and then i go i start to
watch and i was like oh my god
this she's like
100 correct like every scene it's like
wonder woman says like two lines and
then
chris pine and like all the other guys
in the scene have these big monologues
and she just says like two or three
things and i was like oh man
it's like i go oh is this like it's like
is this like a thing
is this like a thing that you like i
know that there's some feminist
equation about movies
i used to date a feminist before rachel
and like like but she was like a staunch
like like like she was trying to be a
lawyer she was like i'm a feminist and
she was telling me about this equation
that they have when you watch in movies
so like i forgot what it's called you
know i'm just remembered it right now
that's why i'm not prepared for it but i
just remember the thing was
are there more than one
main female characters in the movie
are they talking to each other about
something other than a man
so you think that's simple
you know you think like okay
uh you'd be surprised
how many times
it's only one female lead
um
and then if there's two girls two
females they're talking about
a a dude or something and you're like oh
man this is like a real thing that's
going on
um you know
like so strange oh man this is my friend
calling me father bob doing this live
um
hold up guys i'm so sorry
for the people listening like like
they're like what the hell is this guy
doing
um anyways
so you know you'd be surprised what's it
called oh the the beck dale test thank
you see that's why i love you guys
that's what it's called
is that what it's called the beckdale
test or the whatever it's called but
it's like anyways i want you guys to to
look at that like just look at another
movie that next time you watch a movie
is there more than one female lead and
are they talking to each other about
something other than a man if it does
that passes the feminist test but
anyways i'm watching one of them which i
thought was like a great female
empowerment movie you would think but
here i'm watching it with my wife and
she's sitting there looking at it like i
don't like this she doesn't have any
lines and then i'm like every scene i'm
watching i'm like oh man she's so right
it's like
it was i was laughing because it just
made me laugh because i was like oh wow
what a different perspective when you
watch a movie
um but anyways guys that's not even
that's just whatever of stuff that i
wanted to talk about today so you know
it is what it is
uh
lots to talk about today so i'm going to
get right to it i want to get right to
it i would i could tease it and talk
about some other crap that i have i want
to talk about but you know let's just
get right into this
thing right now man
let's get right into it ladies and
gentlemen
game of thrones
the game of tron's
i loved it let me just i'm biased i'm
gonna tell you right now i absolutely
love the new the sequel prequel to
the game of thrones prequel
house of dragons
house of the dragon not house of dragons
house of the dragon sounds like a kung
fu movie house of dragons
so man i'm telling you right now
um
[Music]
it was it was
first of all let me start with this i
didn't want to like it you know i just
didn't i didn't like the last season of
game of thrones i thought it was
you know what i mean
i it just i thought it was lazy i
thought they just rushed through the
story and then it's like even the actors
i felt like they had already checked out
the guy the guy jon snow like literally
three times an episode
in the final season he was like my queen
you're my queen
you're my queen i don't want to be king
you're my queen i don't want to be he
said that like a million times i was
like all right bro i get it she's your
queen you don't want okay and then it
was like some of the choices they made
some of the they just rushed it and so i
just felt like you know you did a
disservice to the people with this final
season okay so i going into this i was
like how is this gonna be good right
it was fantastic
i don't know what it is about medieval
intrigue
about medieval like
violence and and uh all the stuff that
goes on in this world that they created
i was i was all in on it man
um
i enjoyed the set design i enjoyed like
the i i i enjoy the fact that it's like
this you know you're you're finding out
about like the targaryens that we heard
about for so long about these dragons so
now we're seeing it's like 170 years
before the the time of tar you know you
know daenerys uh you know before you
know the queen mother of dragons in the
original game of thrones and now this is
172 years and you know i liked it i i
liked the story i liked their pace of
the story i liked it i like that you
know i like how they set up the
characters i like that we can see who
the villains are it's not you know it's
like we know what's happening and then
at the same time we don't know what's
happening because we know there's such a
surprise
what i liked about the original game of
thrones is the fact that
they killed off
the main character
right away you know they literally like
one of one of them they had no problem
doing that man they had no problem
killing the dude that's on the poster so
that kept you in a like oh wow what's
gonna happen i can't fall in love with
any character you know so
it was great i mean i like i say just to
share story and acting and performances
they took their time they got the right
actors i really i really enjoyed um i
really enjoyed like all of the
performances you know
uh you know
i'm not even gonna try to say all these
people's names because i'm probably
gonna butcher it you know but you know
i'm on the imdb right now and i think
all these people were pretty good you
know patty
whatever that guy's name is
the girl emma another one named matt i
mean there's so many weird names you
know eva
sonja
sonanya i don't even know how to say
these names
but you can go to imdb you can see their
names um
yeah man
uh it was uh
like i'm not gonna try to like
i could pick apart all kinds of little
things and i guess that i will but for
the most part i really liked it i liked
the story like i said i liked the story
i liked uh i liked the pacing of the
show i liked the how they made it i like
to i like seeing the dragons i i just
i like when you have like a really good
story on the backdrop of this like
made-up fantasy world so because the
acting and everything was so
um mesmerizing i would like to say like
the
the the performance were so captivating
is a better word that the special
effects and all that stuff was just
ancillary to everything that was going
on it was just you know what i mean like
you weren't really harping on like oh
this isn't a real city and then you kind
of looked at the special effects or
you're like oh the dragons they did
everything great they they spent the
money and they made the show great
so i liked it um
you know what i'm saying
um
and then i uh um but okay so what can i
pick apart about
the series
you know
um
so i saw somebody in the chat just say
that they they heard it was really woke
what does that really mean
let's not even say that as a negative
okay it's not a negative
the reason why i brought up this thing
about wonder woman with my wife earlier
is the fact that like
these things are real like like
when people are watching a show and
they're they're looking for a character
to relate to
and they see that the main character is
like they don't have a lot of lines or
they're being treated a certain way and
they can relate to that that's powerful
that's something to think about you know
i mean it's not always negative when you
say like oh things are woke but
sometimes it is like i've talked about
the um the what is it uh the eternals
like the eternals was like ridiculous
like that's an example of going too far
the eternals are 7 000 years old but you
got somebody talking in a mexican accent
like it don't even make sense
like it just
you you it takes you out of the movie
because you go why would she be speaking
in an accent that don't even exist yet
on a planet you know what like why would
you make these characters this way why
is there why is there a gay black guy
that wears glasses you know you're like
why is he got glasses on you know
despite the fact that he's decided to be
gay
or whatever like and when you find out
they're robots you know you know what
i'm trying to say like it's like the
whole thing doesn't make sense okay like
it just it just
then you know you get caught in the
the social aspect of like whatever
disney's trump agenda they're trying to
push and then the the artistic integrity
of the story gets lost that's when
something to me is too woke but this
i don't know
here's here's my biggest thing so
when you see a medieval times in a but
this by the way is a fantasy universe so
we don't know the racial component of
this fantasy universe but what we do
know is that people in game of thrones
are always fighting with each other
based off
family land money and whatnot so i would
like to think that
i wouldn't like to think i would think
just being logical and using common
sense they probably racist too
they probably don't like people from the
north like like if everybody in the show
is white okay like if everybody's white
in esteros or whatever the
the westeros or whatever the name of the
place is
they will find something else to
discriminate each other against and they
do it's family the people that live in
the vail the people that live in the
north the people that live in uh you
know the different families the
targaryens the starks there's they have
different reasons to hate each other
when everybody's all white
okay so you would think that
they don't like people for you know
whatever i think that these people would
be like that all right so you know what
i mean i think that's true to the any
story but you know because
we live in a world where people are so
sensitive about these things in the real
world quote unquote now they got to add
stuff so they got this black guy in the
show with with white hair okay and
here's the thing that gets me about this
so if you're gonna have black people
that live in this place or you know
races other than white
so you're telling me that like you know
they're going to treat these people say
equally but you know who
this is this is kind of fun it makes me
laugh because
you're going to add people you're add
races and things like that and pretend
like everybody's like kumbaya
but it's funny how women are still
treated the same in every universe
you know what i mean like it's still the
same the age-old
story the new coming to america had this
you know every every show or something
about this where there's some kind of
like princess who can't
that the men
can't allow her to be queen because
she's a woman like no matter what
universe you're talking about hollywood
writes the same story over and over
again
women aren't allowed to rule over men
that's always the theme so i don't care
how woke this [ __ ] is they still did the
same thing
172 years before what's-her-face
you know
it's the same thing the king's daughter
people are gonna fight that she
shouldn't be allowed to be the queen why
because she's a woman
but yet they have a black guy
on the small court
of the king you know like it's nothing
so that's where you go all right so
you've decided to show that who's that
for you know what i'm saying like who's
that for so
once you can get past that
it's like once you can get past that
like stop thinking like don't think
about it don't let the outside world and
social media affect your enjoyment of
something like let yourself suspend your
disbelief because you can nitpick and
pick this apart for days and days and
days every single show you watch every
single thing you can find something you
can find wrong at a certain point we
just have to be like hey let's just
enjoy this for what it is
so
you know what i mean
that's how i that's just how i feel
about it
it you know what i mean it's just like
because in one hand you want to go oh
they're being woke because they have
this but on the other hand they still
doing the same thing they've always done
if there's a woman
she's not allowed to be anything more
than being a woman because
you know people won't
you know people won't like they won't
like that i mean it's just it's so
strange that they still kept that
you know what i mean so
i don't know
i i think if you're like you know i can
see how like you're a person that you
you could see the influence of social
culture
social media and everything we watch now
and sometimes it's run amok
but i would just like to say to you like
find a way to just accept that and then
try to enjoy the artistic integrity of
whatever else you're watching you know
because if you harp on that stuff you'll
drive yourself crazy and i'm that guy
trust me i know
i'm that guy i i look at things and i
sometimes i'm like how the hell why is
this that and this and i and partly
because i think like that because i'm
older and i've lived through certain
things and the other part of it is like
it's for comedic value too like a lot of
things i [ __ ] about and say it's just
because that's my brand you know what i
mean people you know people like talking
smack about me talking about stuff so
then i still do it you know what i mean
it's like i'm trolling you anybody that
says oh you complain too much it's like
oh i do it's like i'm i'm trolling you
[ __ ] that's why i do it
you know what i mean that's that's i
love doing that it's just it's just part
of like with the thing so you try to
find a balance so i totally get the
people that are in chat right now who
are like it's too woke it's to this is
too that i'm with you 100
so once you see that
accept it and then try to enjoy it and i
feel like the show is super enjoyable i
can't wait to see where it goes to see
who dies to see who wins to see like you
know uh these characters
like it's so subtle like one spoiler is
like you know the hand of the king
you know you could tell he's this sort
of power hungry
weasel type guy but super smart and
super like and he's playing the
political game like he knows
you know and he's like telling his
daughter like you know the king just
went through a tragedy and he's like
telling his daughter go go see the king
you know go see the king you know and
he's like
he's like implying without saying like
you know
go flirt with him uh you know wear
something [ __ ] or like wear something
you know of the time you know what i
mean he just felt like that i felt like
man this guy's a dog he's sending his
daughter so it's like that's that world
man it's like medieval and like there's
killing it cutting off dicks and cutting
off arms and and it's just you know
dragons are burning people alive and
like you know what i mean that's that
world so i like that they're like lean
into it you know lean
into it man i love i love savagery and
adult this ain't for kids so let's stop
acting like it is for kids and and then
let's let parents at home
figure out you know hey parents at home
put on your child locks you know and all
that stuff because us adults we out here
living our life and we enjoy us some
house of the dragons game of thrones and
i give it 10 woo-woos
[Music]
i don't know if that was 10 it was
probably more
um
um so
anyways man
there was that so that was house of
dragons
review
loved it so much and if you have any
questions and i'm gonna be talking about
this bad boy every single damn week i
think because i loved it so much but
let's now get a word from our sponsor at
better help
better help better help y'all look
therapy
life coaching
those types of things i think they're
super important and they've been super
helpful for my life
and i highly recommend it therapy is not
gonna solve your problems man but it's
gonna help you recognize patterns that
you don't see it's gonna help you see
something that hey you know you may feel
this way because of a b and c and the
factors that you haven't even thought of
with a professional who can recognize
these things it's you know you don't go
when it's bad you don't have to go just
because you feel bad sometimes you just
need to go just to help you even
improve your own situation therapy
therapy is good for bad situations and
it's good for just like you know giving
yourself a pick-me-up in the brain brain
work man it's important you know so
um
i have my own personal experience
actually real quick is like just
recently i've been trying to deal with
my mom and i having dementia and my
therapist is talking to me about like
actually feeling those feelings and stop
compartmentalizing because that's what
i've been doing what i like to do is
like i think about something that starts
to make me feel bad and then i mix put
some logic around it and then i switch
to the next topic because then i haven't
dealt with it and so i saw my mom and i
let myself feel exactly what i was
feeling and what was i thinking about
and it just made me think about not just
the dementia it made me think about oh
man my mom's getting older and she's
like you know she has trouble walking
and i'm looking at her and i'm thinking
to myself oh man
i this is really all the things that
bugged me and i really was glad that i
talked about it you know what i mean so
you might have some things like that
that you want to talk about there are
plenty of ways to support a healthy
brain like learning a language or taking
power naps there's also better help
online therapy better help is online
therapy that offers video phone and even
live chat only therapy sessions so you
don't have to see anyone on camera if
you don't want to our listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
griffin that's better h-e-l-p-com
griffin
okay
what else we got here
um
oh
we got this i
let's talk about
she hulk okay she-hulk old school
character i mean i mean she-hulk's been
around man
you know
she-hulk has been around so it's like i
know somebody was like she-hulk they
think she-hulk is woke what do i think
about she-hulk um you know i saw the um
god damn it's really hot in my office
you guys are gonna see but you can't see
but
i am taking my pants off
[Laughter]
this is the only fans content
[Laughter]
so anyways um
i like she-hulk
she-hulk is on disney pulse plus it's a
part of the mcu marvel universe so they
had uh you know they had um what you
call it um
the hulk you know they had uh bruce
banner
in it played by mark ruffalo he was in
it he's a real funny dude i like how
funny he is
so
this was like what do i think about this
show but i think i also have did i pull
up the imdb
for uh she-hulk i thought i did
wait did i i thought i did i think i did
um let me just let me just put it in
real quick so i can go to it
yeah here we go
no
wow there was another tv series
so the tv series is actually called
she-hawk attorney at law
um the description they have on imdb is
jennifer wade walters is that her name
jennifer walters navigates the
complicated life of a single
30-something attorney who also happens
to be a green six foot seven inch super
powered hulk
so yeah i mean that's a great that's the
pitch line you know
for the for the show
and i think she's doing a pretty good
job the the
girl playing jennifer and you know this
show let's say let's talk about the
actual show so the show is like a campy
90s late 80s sitcom type show it kind of
the the the the first the first episode
is like you know so
you know bruce banner
the hulk is in it a lot they're cousins
apparently they're cousins and then you
know they're they're going on a trip
they get into a car accident something
happens and then she turns into uh you
know she gets she hulk you know what i
mean
so
and then it's just about it's kind of
like an origin story of like it's like
they had to like explain
it was like a a good like 30 minute
whatever explanation of this is how she
became she-hulk this is how she's
dealing with it and here we go because
we have 10 years of like the hulk like
we know that the hulk we there was two
other movies about the hulk and you know
how he was like a maniac and like you
know he took all this time to like you
know control his you know two sides so
we know that it takes a long time so in
this the woke part of this is like well
you know they're like well women have to
have to deal with anger and all this
kind of stuff so they're more equipped
to be the hulk than a man and you know
that was part of the explanation
did i buy how she became the hawk no i
thought it was like a lazy cheesy way
for her to be to become the hulk but i'm
still all in it was campy it was funny
it was uh it was well acted i think it
was well made i thought the special
effects and everything was great they
didn't cheat us on that they gave us
everything we wanted on that and i
thought it was like oh well this is cool
like i like the hulk universe like other
than like worrying about avengers and
all that stuff i like seeing like this
is the hulk being a hulk and like this
is like you know hulk stuff
you know so then she's like an attorney
so that's going to be like sort of like
an episodic you know it's like it's a
it's an attorney show
it's a fun attorney show
uh it she just so happens to be the hulk
you know what i mean so
i i like this and then they also like
you know they they i always wondered
what they were going to do about the
hulk's arm because remember he put on an
end game he put on the the glove they
had the infinity stones he snapped a
half of his body got seared and it's
like he never really healed and so they
actually explained that too so they give
you everything you need they go like oh
okay so the hulk's gonna be cool now you
know everything you need about
the the this is it is what it is like if
you if you're not into like funny
campy type stuff you're not gonna like
this i'm gonna tell you right now you're
not gonna like it
but if you just want like a this reminds
me of a show that you would be like oh
this is a good guilty pleasure they're
probably gonna have a lot of like
anytime they make like a woman super
strong in a show
you know whether it be wonder woman or
whatever kind of thing like that there's
always going to be that aspect of
you know men
are going to be acting like well you're
just a woman and then she's going to be
like well i'm also the hulk you know
what i mean and then it's gonna be like
i'm sure there's gonna be a lot of story
lines like that there's gonna be plenty
of villains and plenty of fun stuff but
as of right now
i enjoyed it
you know what i mean
i enjoy the damn thing um
yeah so it stars uh
what's her name tatiana masalami hope i
said her name light mark ruffalo and
ginger gonzaga gonzaga and shout out to
ginger she was on i'm dying up here so i
know ginger from that to when i saw her
i was like yeah actually i should get
ginger on the podcast actually you know
i'm gonna see if i can get her on the
podcast so uh that that's that you know
that's good you know and then
who knows if
mark ruffalo is gonna be in
um oh wow when you look on imdb he's in
nine episodes
so that's pretty cool
so let me talk about this now because
this is something i actually wanted to
talk about
you know it's weird now your generation
when i say your generation you young
people the old heads that are watching
right now y'all know
uh y'all with me on this but
it's
when when i was growing up
movies
were held to a super high standard and
they were put on a pedestal so like you
did movies because you wanted to be a
movie star and you didn't do tv like if
you were in movies you didn't do tv like
you would rarely see
movie stars
doing television that would be slumming
it that would be considered like
but now
with the age of netflix putting big time
movies on our little screen
the lines are blurred and so now it's
just it doesn't matter
so now it doesn't matter and i like that
i like that mark ruffalo who's like this
hulk movie star and hulk and does has
done a bunch of movies
is just in this great streaming disney
plus
series it gives it some legitimacy it
gives it some like you know you know it
just you feel like you're watching a
great product because they have these
people in it
i remember i was on um
[Music]
this star show with patrick stewart
you know and patrick stewart was telling
me how when he first was doing
uh
star trek that his actor friends
were kind of clowning him about that
like looking down on him at that time
because it was like oh what are you
doing television for
but now you know things are different
because even i would say like five six
seven years ago
when people were doing tv you would hear
some like absorbent like some huge
salary they were getting to convince
that person to do tv now it's like the
blinds are blurred now it's just kind of
like everybody's doing everything if the
product if the project is good because i
much prefer
right now i'm gonna tell you right now
i like marvel television
more than i like marvel movies ever
since end game like i like the
television i like loki
look i even like she-hulk right now i
like um i liked uh uh black um not black
widow uh hawkeye i liked i just
i like telling a longer story
eight hours of content
or even four hours of content if it's a
30 minute show
i prefer i much prefer having all that
content and really getting to know all
these people as opposed to like some
two hour movie that they're leaving out
a bunch of stuff and then we gotta wait
two three years to see the next one
give me all this content and then come
out with another show you know even like
a little moon night even as little as
little as even though moonlight it
started good and then it just it tapered
off but still that was a great bunch of
content so now we got she-hulk and keep
going just keep making these great
marvel
things and then then you can still put
them in the movies like i liked um
what is it what it was at the falcon and
winter soldier i thought that was a
great series that had a lot of little
keys that's gonna lead to
the the movies that they're gonna come
out with so i love these kind of like
these tv shows are like companion pieces
to the movies then we're just it's
always in our head it's like you know
it's like
we're continuously
thinking about it so we'll see
you know and i understand i still see
the comments i understand the mcu you
know disney and these people they got
they got a level of wokeness to them
that they're trying to put an agenda out
and that's because people are afraid
people are afraid
not of
they're afraid of what they think people
are gonna think i mean it's actually
talking down to the fans as if we can't
differentiate between like fiction and
fantasy and and uh you know it's like
there it's like over correcting right
now which i think sucks but you know
what we're here and we're here try to
enjoy it guys just try to enjoy it as
best you can so i liked it five woo-woos
for she-hulk i can't wait i'm gonna
watch the whole season i'm i'm in they
got me hooked like i say it was a campy
cheesy mess in terms of like you know
what i mean like it's like one of those
guilty pleasures oh do you watch
she-hulk you know and it's like i like i
i think it's like i love i love old
school sitcoms shows it reminds me of
like
it reminds me like moonlighting with
bruce willis i don't know if you guys
the old people remember that just a fun
detective show i feel like this is gonna
be like that a fun lawyer show with the
hulk involved so
yeah sometimes great stories can still
be woke because i see somebody in the
chat uh
our
whatever your name is i prefer great
stories woke or not oh yeah exactly i
totally agree with you that's what i'm
saying if it's a great story and they
still have like a considerable amount of
like what you think is social wokeness
that they're trying to portray but if
you tell a great story who cares
who cares and that's how i feel about
you know what you call it um
you know whatever you call it
you know the gate like game of thrones
and she-hulk you know what i mean
um yeah oh somebody said they kind of
used ally mcbeal as some inspiration
yeah
exactly you know what i mean like i love
a good heroine you know what i mean that
didn't sound right but i said it i said
it right but it sounded like heroin
but isn't it isn't that how you say both
words
like heroin the drug and heroin the
female
why do we have to make a hero just a
female hero just a hero who cares i like
a good strong female lead so we'll see
how this goes we'll see how it goes i
mean it could go off the rails
you know what i mean so it doesn't
matter like i'm not even gonna answer
that question lost because that to me
that's a ridiculous question you know
who cares you know what i mean like i
don't care
you know like it's like
just just
just watch the show man regardless of
who's in it or who's not in it just
watch the show
um
yeah so anyways that is my she-hulk
review
and i enjoyed it and i hope you enjoyed
the review and you know i'll probably be
talking about that a bunch of a bunch
this week too so she-hulk
got some sad news that i saw
um
a story that
i think this is sad because i like going
to the movie theaters but one of the the
second largest movie theater chain may
be filing for bankruptcy
turns out that regal theaters looks like
it's not going to
they're having trouble staying in
business
so i don't know what this means man it's
like are movie theaters going away or
it's you know
i don't i don't even know what they're
gonna do i mean i think a lot of it has
to do with like the mall business going
out of business like people aren't going
to the malls anymore they're not
shopping you know and like the the the
mall used to be like the watering hole
you know like we would go
and this is where you would see a bunch
of people you see the new trends and
fashions you watch movies you get you
know you get your sneakers you get you
know your food you know it's like
i don't know and so these malls are
going away and then that's where a lot
of movie theaters are and maybe the rent
is too high the people that own the
malls and these theaters can't support
because you got to think if like you got
a big movie theater in a mall that your
rent is like some
crazy amount of rent so
i don't know what that's going to take i
mean is it going to take like you know
people lowering they're going to stop
trying to price gouge the theaters and
the theaters price cows
us so i don't know
you know but it just looks like
and then apparently this caused the amc
stock to drop
you know
so it looks like yeah shares in the
cinema world crashed as much as 80 in
london on friday after wall street
journal reported that the world's second
largest theater chain had spoken to
lawyers
to advise on the bankruptcy process in
the united states and the united kingdom
the company's stock fell 20
uh the news also contributed to the
plunge of more than 30 in the shares of
amc the world's largest movie theater
chain
man
like i have the amc app and i i pay for
that you know even when i don't go to
the movies because i want to support i
mean
i don't know it just sucks man i hope
that the movie theaters don't go out of
business because i still enjoy going to
the movies but i'm from a different era
different generation i don't know if
young people even like going to the
movies anymore i don't know if they you
know
i don't know what you what do you guys
think do you still do you still like
going to the movies let me know in the
chat you know
um
i'm gonna put a poll up
do you still like going to the movie
theater movie
theater
yes or no
i don't know
i mean i do
so but this could be a thing where young
people are just like nah i just want to
be home watching netflix or i just want
to watch stuff on my phone
and that's fair you know that's a fair
feeling if you're a young person and you
don't remember
going to the movie theater or you don't
you know it was never a thing for you
but it was always a thing for me i
remember when i was even a kid i was an
only child you know 12 13 years old and
i would just tell my mom i want to go to
movies and you know my mom worked and
she was busy so i remember taking the
bus
and going down to westwood and going to
see movies by myself i was like yes
nobody would go i would just go and i
was like man i just love that experience
i've had some great times
watching movies in the theaters man some
of my fondest memories are in the movie
movie theaters when it comes to watching
entertainment
i remember watching return of the jedi
and i was old enough then to just be
like really understanding what was like
oh wow we're in you know and then like
hearing this story like i don't remember
i don't remember empire strikes back as
much it was like right around that age
you know six seven eight you know it's
like so now when you get to like nine
ten eleven you know you really start to
retain things you know so star wars
don't even it was nothing to me you know
because like i was born in 72 so star
wars was like 77 so you're like four or
five years old who cares then return of
the jedi i'm like six seven eight and
then it's like you know then i'm going
with my mom to see return of the jedi
and and we're in the theaters and what i
remember the most about return of the
jedi is
that was the installation of thx sound
that
[Music]
you know what i mean whatever that in
that sort of like surround sound 3d
where the this you know the sound filled
the whole theater they had different
speakers and all this stuff so i
remember that was the the introduction
of that and it made the movie amazing so
that was a great movie experience i
remember watching jurassic park for the
first time in theaters
i saw jurassic park like nine times in a
movie theater back in 1990 or whatever
it was whenever it came out because that
was the first time
cgi looked like that
and i remember being in the theater and
seeing that dinosaur come across the
screen just being like
wow
now y'all don't even understand because
cgi is everywhere like you know it
doesn't even matter now but at the time
that to make it look so real you know
quote-unquote was amazing
so
i don't know
that's just i remember watching
i remember my mom and her friend
uh they wanted to go to the movies and
my mom took me and we were going to go
see indiana jones
and i was like i won't say indiana jones
i don't even know what the hell that was
i think i've told this story before but
that's just another great movie
experience i had i remember coming home
from the theater and i wanted a whip and
a hat and a leather jacket i was so
hooked on that so going to the theater
is like it's such a
fun
memorable
experience man
that movie i went to go see by myself i
remember what it was it was aliens
it was aliens too
i mean what a great movie that was so
i just remember how maybe yeah i
remember the first imax movie you went
to and that experience look
like i don't mind watching a movie at
home like it's great too when you're
just at the comfort of your home and
watching it at your own pace but there's
nothing like still watching that same
movie on the big screen man
it's just wow
like avengers end game and all the
movies that i've seen in the theaters
even the recent movies i just
love
that experience
more than anything else
so i hope the movie business doesn't go
out of business but you know
i hope it works out for
you know i just hope it works out you
know what i mean
um
what's another another oh so another
strange story that's going on and this
one is really weird shout out to my new
producer kristen she came she sent me
these things
but
there's this weird story that i wanted
to finish with
uh let me let me put a little bookmark
for myself so i know what's going on
here all right here we go
this is a weird story man orcas
are attacking boats
near europe it might be a fad
so apparently
whales
have trends that they do these things
for a little while and then they stop
like the whale community is like ah
we're done attacking boats let's do
something else now and apparently that's
something that they
there's something that that they're
talking about has happened quite quite
frequently man
they go scientists aren't sure why the
orcas are going after rudders but the
incident near france was farther north
than previous encounters
you know and then they start talking
about
they have other related facts about
killer whales but dolphins which are
also social
creatures like orcas also have fads
the study in the biology letters
reported that wild dolphins in southern
australia may have gotten into cool new
trends of
tail walking thanks to a dolphin that
was temporarily housed in a
rehabilitation center as a calf like
imagine
like imagine that like whales are doing
some sort of weird crap
and then they just stop doing that weird
crap because they're just kind of over
it
i mean the the animal kingdom is like
super weird like that huh
um
[Music]
i mean it's like
oh and i i noticed that 89 of you
66 votes and 89 of you say
you still like going to the movie
theater so that 11 are monsters
[Laughter]
yeah so that's weird man so i you know i
i
i don't know if you've ever been to like
sea world or anything place like that
i've gone like once or twice but i never
liked it i don't like places like that
because even as a kid i kind of felt
like should these things be locked up
like this like how can that be fun like
if normally your pool is like as big as
the ocean and that got you in this
little thing that can't be
that can't be
a fun time right
so
yeah so apparently like uh these orcas
have like a they did something else
i forgot i read something they did like
where they were doing they there's like
a list of funny things that the the
these orcas have done
uh let's say the trend continued for
over a decade let's see what is this a
few years after the dolphin was tagged
and released back yeah so that's that
tail walking thing so then that one you
know dolphin did it and then a bunch of
dolphins started doing it and then it
just got played out and then they
stopped doing it so right now they're
doing this we're gonna tear we're gonna
go after boats and then they're just
gonna stop doing it so that's weird
animal kingdom is super bizarre man
all right guys um
i actually got to cut it just actually i
was going to say i got to cut it short
but it's been 50 something minutes i got
to get i got to go help my friend out
you know see what happened with this
he took this thing out of his stomach so
let's see how you know let's see how
that goes but
this week's
chat
i got to put up i got to make a graphic
for this but the the rap recap y'all
uh shout out to dj dirty who sent me
some beats fishy also sent me some more
beats but
we got some new beats and we'll use uh i
don't know we know which one
let's see which one i don't know if i i
think i liked this one but i want to
thank y'all for
uh
watching listening
[Music]
to
griffin
with griffin
oh this g dirty beat
get you out your seat
[Music]
this week
making one a little big
[Music]
house of the dragon
nothing rhymes with dragon
like a flagging
sagging
[Music]
different strokes
it's not a hoax
[Music]
thanks for watching reference griffin
here's another one of his beats and then
we'll get the hell out of here
i want to thank the chat thank everybody
for being here once again
griffin with griffin tell your friends
yeah and if you want to send a beat you
can email me at eric
ericgriffin.com
that's my name
another beat
here we go
j30
[Music]
um
[Music]
everybody
[Music]
guess what else i'm on twitch
[Music]
splashing
[Music]
i don't know what